the first thing people want from their
government is safety
security and the democrats are now an
insurrectionary party the democratic
debate starts
who did you think had the best chance to
go up against trump bernie sanders a
lifelong communist elizabeth warren is
another pathological liar i'm shocked
that the democrats have kept
biden in the race i mean it's
unbelievable so do you think the
debate's going to happen
between the two of them all the leaders
of the democrat party are communists
they're racists and they have no respect
for american principles
to say blanket statement all these
democrats are communists
you're doing what they're doing what's
capitalism to what socialism to what's
communism to you
communism is this it's a one-party
system it's redistribution of income
it's shutting down free speech none of
this violence could take place if it
weren't for the democratic party
crowds of gangsters the anti-fall black
lives matter
hooligans you cannot disagree with the
left without
being denounced as a racist america
liberated blacks blacks and slave blacks
what does that have to do with communism
because the ideology of the democrat
party is
anybody who disagrees that we have
systemic racism is a racist
there's an ideology war going on today
it's a civil war
and the democrats are called the racists
that they are i know
that we have a chance of winning
[Music]
my guest today is david horowitz who's a
five times or six time new york time
best seller when you write as many
bestsellers as he does
you lose count but his best book so far
right now is the one that just came out
the title of the book is trump will
smash the left
and win and by the way he's also
liked he's loved he's hated he's
controversial
he said a lot of different things his
background is going from a full-on
communist
to conservative we'll find out why that
is but the one thing i want to give him
credit for that i don't think a lot of
people talk about
and he doesn't even know this is the
angle i'm taking one of my
favorite books i read in the last few
years the day it came out i bought it
it was called the hard things about hard
things by a guy named ben horowitz
ben horowitz sold his company to hp for
1.6 billion dollars cash
ben is today worth roughly 3.5 billion
dollars he's written a couple books i
read all of them
ben happens to be david's son
so david before we get started all these
accolades the biggest accomplishment is
what is it like to be able to say you
raised a son that's now a billionaire
he's so smart i have two sons who are
smarter than i
am uh and they've lived happier lives as
a result that
not involved in politics one is in the
music industry
and ben of course is silicon valley
uh-huh i i don't know where they get
their smarts
let me ask you when when when did you
know ben had what it took to go into
business like
did you have signs early on where you
saw the entrepreneur in him making money
or was it kind of like all of a sudden
to colombia because of the
contemporary sibling that's my alma
mater
for us parents who have little ones i
got an eight a six and a four year old
what were some values and principle you
passed down to your kids were there
i sat down with rfk robert f kennedy jr
and he said growing up in the kennedy
family
one of the cultural things they did as
family is every night they debated it
was always a debate a debate a debate
you know you talked to the bush family
the bush family which i interviewed we
had at our event last year family is a
disaster for the next generation what
i'm trying but but
if there's pass down to your kids
everybody gets knocked down the trick is
getting up
that's the one thing that's the one
thing was there were there any rituals
any rituals that are also unique to your
family i
i try to encourage them i think
everybody should
try to pick a profession or a job
that makes them want to get up in the
morning every day that's another big
thing
i know i've met a lot of accountants who
are bored silly
you know for a man of many words you
don't have a lot of words about
parenting i think you're keeping a
secret you don't want to tell the rest
of us who are inspired
support your kids okay
supported them whatever they've you know
whatever direction they've gone
well first of all i applaud you i
applaud you for raising uh uh
great kids who do very uh good for
themselves more power to you
uh for doing that because ben is
impacting a lot of people in the
business world
you have in the political world so now
let's talk about the book that you wrote
which is trump will smash the left and
win why
why not let's um blitz is the title
blitz trump will smash the left trump
will smash the left and win
why will trump smash the left and why
not trump will win
actually um i'm sure you know this about
books
others have no control over their titles
so my title was given it by chris ruddy
was the publisher and it was a marketing
genius
and uh that's the question everybody
asked me when they get me on the show
is why do you think trump will smash the
left and win
so why do you think he'll win well
because americans aren't stupid
um they you know it's it's interesting
if you watch cnn you'll never see a riot
but they can't yet block the trump
campaign from buying
um and you know video ad space
that will show you the riots the first
thing people want from their government
and this is true
whatever the government is uh
is safety security
and the democrats are now a a
an insurrectionary party they're
anti-american
they support the violence none of this
violence could take place if it weren't
for the democrat party
every city that's erupted is 100
controlled by the democrats and it has
been for 50 to 100
years um it's the democrats who've held
back the police i mean this
mayor in portland should be arrested
immediately
for what he's doing innocent people are
getting killed
billions of dollars of property damage
is taking place and they have to go all
these democrats to then
go to trump and ask for federal money
to bail out their bankrupt cities
but i you know people can see what's
going on
and everybody as i say wants safety
you know this ad that trump is running
now about 9 11
uh you know about your 9-1-1 calls
um where you have to wait five days for
a response from police
i think that that would send chills up
the spine of any suburban mother
and father you want your kids to be safe
you don't want these
crowds of of criminals
uh gangsters is what they are the
anti-far black lives matter
hooligans mulligan is kind of a soviet
term isn't it i
shouldn't use it but you know what
they're roaming your streets
burning things you know launching
uh explosives and it's just terrible
what they've gotten away with
and then you have all these democrat um
in washington lying
i mean it's one thing look every
politician lies we all know that
that you know but they call it spin
because
some of them are white lies some of them
are shading of the truth
you get a democrat on the tube these
days and says
that these are peaceful protests and you
have to say
you need your head examined why are you
saying
something that i can see with my own
eyes is a
complete lie so i i think that
trump will gain a majority that way
also i mean the main thing that makes
trump different
don't forget trump is his second thought
or like me
that is he he was a liberal you know
i guess that the clinton's wedding
supports all these liberal causes
but he also was a patriot and the
democrat party is now an anti-american
party it's true it's destroying the
country
uh it sides with our enemies both
these vicious chinese who are conducting
a biological warfare against the world
not to mention the iranian mullahs who
are nazis
the democrats will defend them against
trump too
people can see that and they're not
going to support the democrats as a
result
the only joker in the pack is the
mail and fraud which the democrats are
committed to
and i think trump is very right to raise
this as an issue
you have to realize i there was an
election in new york three weeks ago
something like that they still don't
know what the result is because of the
mail-in ballot fraud
so uh i think we're in for some pretty
rough times this fall
do you think we're going to see a debate
between the two of them because i know
biden agreed to three of them do you
think we're actually going to see the
baby
i i'm shocked that the democrats have
kept
biden in the race i mean it's
unbelievable
you you you have to be consumed
with a rabid hatred of trump
to even consider that biden
is a candidate even before he got
dementia
i mean i don't know that he can tie his
own shoelaces these days but even before
he got dementia
he's a nasty piece of work i don't know
how he gets the reputation of being
uncle joe or some good guy
you know he's a bully
he he he will say anything he's a
political [ __ ]
um and he's a he's got a mafiosi
mentality you look at the way he
threatened the
prime minister of the of ukraine you
know i'm gonna get on a plane if if you
haven't
fired this prosecutor who's going after
my corrupt son
uh i'm going to take a billion dollars
uh
out of your pocket that the congress has
already voted for you
and then the same son of a [ __ ] biden
he attacks trump who didn't give a quid
pro quo to the ukrainians
and is perfectly comfortable with you
know trying to overthrow him
i can't say bad enough things about joe
i've never liked joe biden
i can't say bad enough things about him
he's made every
immediate member of his family his wife
his sister when we can't distinguish
between
his brother his son they're all
millionaires and multi-millionaires off
the government tit
arranged by joe biden
what what can you say about this guy
that's positive unless you're lying
so now you believe it he's supporting
you know bernie sanders program bernie
sanders a lifelong
communist they're probably never a
member of the party
but he's defended every communist
dictator and every communist atrocity
um you know for 60 years
learn nothing and he's an angry nasty
piece of work
he ate he hates billionaires he doesn't
hate millionaires because he is one
i mean anyway
so do you think the debate's gonna
happen between the two of them
i can't answer that i i sure
yes it looks like the democrats are
committed
to running this you know it's like
weekend at bernie's that film where they
wheel a corpse around by the way have
you seen dinesh the sources documentary
because you're
some of the stuff you're talking about
it's in his new documentary
no i haven't seen it dinesh i've known
dinesh since he was
just came out of college he's a very
brilliant young man
i guess he's not as young anymore
but i always enjoy listening to dinesh
if you were an
ally let's just say as a conservative
yourself
if the democrats were were to have hired
you hypothetically i know this is not
going to happen
if they were to have hired you and said
look we want a hundred percent
uh accurate answers here they put you on
a lie detective test
and said here's the panel of all the
candidates that we have going up against
trump
who do you think stands the best chance
going up against trump
pre you know when they put their
candidates up i'm talking about buddha
[ __ ] i'm
all these guys two men and women all the
leaders of the democratic party
are communists they're racists
and they have no respect for american
principles you can't declare
a resistance to a duly elected president
and not be an enemy of this country our
whole democracy is based on the peaceful
transition of power
that's why we have honeymoons for
incoming presidents barack obama who is
an extreme
leftist got a honeymoon that lasted more
than a year
trump didn't get seven seconds they
you know met at a hotel at the mandarin
oriental
this is all in my book blitz by the way
at the mandarin oriental in washington
pelosi was there
elizabeth warren was there the
communists
the street communists who managed occupy
wall street the anti-fog people they
were all there
and they formed a resistance to a duly
elected president
the last time that happened was in 1860
when lincoln was elected
then they conducted this phony
impeachment process for three years
knowing from the outset that it was
based on lies
that there was no no evidence imagine
imagine accusing the president of the
united states
of being a traitor of being in putin's
pocket
of putin to having something over his
head which nancy pelosi is doing
to this day to run him you want to hurt
the american people that's what you do
to their commander-in-chief
if you are an enemy you know if the
mullahs had a psychological warfare unit
that's what they would be dennis they
are doing
undoubtedly i mean one of them who's
been nominated or is mentioned as a lead
is the head of the black caucus
karen bass she's a communist
she's that was a leader of the vince
ramos brigades which was run by cuban
intelligence uh for decades
that's the kind of people that they they
uh have
all that said i think that it would be
stupid not to
pick susan rice who's a pathological
liar who lied
about the benghazi buried our heroes in
benghazi with her lies
she's the only one who's really
qualified to be a
vice president because the vice
president is going to be president
but i agree i guess what i was asking
was the final one what i was asking one
is
the the democratic debate starts they
have all these candidates on the
uh uh stage right who do you think
before all of a sudden one day before
super tuesday like oh we're choosing
biden and buddhiche dropped out and mary
and warren and sanders everybody dropped
out who did you think
had the best chance to go up against
trump not that they could beat him who
trump yeah you know i'll stick with rice
i mean i
elizabeth warren is uh very dangerous
because she's
quite smart um but she's
another pathological liar and also a
very dangerous
individual um she has called for
the he said well she said what we need
are race conscious
laws so she said she uh as you know
lied about her ethnicity to get a cushy
job at harvard
uh and that you know probably the most
the scariest thing she said is on day
one when i'm president i'm gonna destroy
the fracking industry
put 250 000 people out of work
um these are communist ideologues is
what they are
and i i use that term really advisedly
i don't say lightly people are communist
you know you could describe them as
fascists it's the same thing
um same mentality you look at how they
set out to destroy
attorney general bart that wouldn't let
him get a word in edgewise
no conducted it was a you know a public
burning is what that
hearing was uh and the only thing worse
than that was the
the kavanaugh where they trying to
destroy this guy's life
uh you know on the basis of
lies that were transparent lies
that uh christine ford
so so so for me here's my question for
you for somebody that was
raised around communism and socialism
and capitalism and i'm a capitalist
myself as a conservative
to say blanket you know a blanket
statement all these democrats are
communists that's
that's you're doing what they're doing
you're making an extreme statement that
just gets people i have a whole book a
chapter of my book blitz
called green communism and you just look
at the green new deal well
maybe define what communism means to you
what does communism mean
you know it's redistribution of income
it's shutting down
free speech the democrat party is a
party and that has
attacked the first amendment uh up
you know up and down the line um
if you look at the universities which
are all run by democrats
a conservative is a faculty member is as
rare as a unicorn they've been purging
university faculties for 50 years
they've
you know rewritten i i have not been
able to go to a college campus without a
bodyguard
for 20 years and i i don't go anymore
the last time i spoke was at dartmouth
where they paid
60 000 a year tuition
in advance of my appearance they used uh
slanders from the southern poverty law
center a 600 million dollar hate machine
no evidence no basis call me anti-muslim
i i am not anti-muslim i'm anti-jihadist
they don't make that distinction the
whole democratic party is called
trump anti-muslim because he's picked
six or seven countries that obama
banned immigration from because they're
terrorist states or failed states
and can't vet you know the new york
times routinely calls him anti-muslim
that's communism then you look at the
green new deal i'll
just give you one example the green new
deal
is demanding the uh elimination
of all gasoline-driven cars within a
10-year period or the planet will
disappear
10 years i looked it up on the internet
there's 276
million gasoline driven cars in the
united states
these are big ticket items for middle
class people
uh and also people are very attached to
their cars they're symbols of their
freedom you get in your car and go
anywhere anytime
uh which is why you know a lot of these
public uh rail uh system what does that
have to do with communism though what
does that have to do with communism
tell me how you could eliminate 276
million automobiles
in a 10-year period without instituting
a police state
and when you ask them they're pretty
frank about it
they don't use my language uh you ask
the green new deal whether it's cortez
actually in her
in that her announcement of the green
new deal
but you know cory booker in defending it
all of them
they say saving the planet is more
um a bigger threat a bigger
uh priority than defeating the nazis but
it's really the same thing
so we had a world war ii mobilization
yeah and we incarcerated or roosevelt a
liberal
incarcerated 120 000 japanese americans
during this martial law that's what they
want martial law
do you have any doubt whatsoever since
they have
defined everybody who disagrees with
them you know
uh as a racist you know i've read the
andy phi
handbook well what they say is anybody
who disagrees with us
is either a fascist or a white
supremacist
and has to be suppressed by any means
necessary
including violence or killing so so
here's my question
tell me the democrat that's denounced
andy here's my question for you the
the part that for me i know where i
write the best-selling
book in america is how to be an
anti-racist
this is by a guy who says there's no
such thing as
not not racist what's your point but
what does that have to do with communism
though
because the ideology of the democrat
party is
anybody who disagrees let's say about
affirmative action
anybody who disagrees that we have
systemic racism
is a racist and and i call that
strategic
i don't call that it's manipulative
don't get me wrong it's hardcore
what's the difference between that and
anti-soviet no no no no
communism to me wait a minute communists
let's define communism feminism is
okay so this to me it's taxes
zero percent taxes to 33.5 to me it's
about capitalism
okay the moment we cross 33 and a half
we're getting close to socialism so
socialism from 50 percent
anywhere upwards to 100 is social 100 is
communism
you mean to tell me these guys are 100
trillion dollar
100 trillion dollar uh
program the green new deal and 30
trillion
are you talking about they want to shut
down the entire fossil fuel industry
that's not communism that's socialism
so then so then why don't you do this
you're the one that's been in this world
your entire life
and you're a former uh your parents were
card holding you know card members of
you know
yeah so so why don't you to me what i
want to learn from you
from your life because i truly want to
learn from you is the following
what is your definition instead of
giving the stories just give me the
definition
what's capitalism to you what's
socialism to you what's communism to you
here if you think there's two ways of
looking
at uh what they call racial inequity
okay look at the way they treat the
coronavirus
it discriminates against black people
the system
discriminates that's our white people's
fault
uh that more blacks blacks are more
vulnerable
to coronavirus
what's the reality the reality is
that obesity
is one of three comorbid factors
in in making people die from coronavirus
the other two are connected to obesity
high blood pressure and diabetes
black americans are off the charts
obese uh that's their
cultural habits unfortunately the way
you can just look this up these are
government statistics
what is 80 percent 80 of black women
are obese that's why though
it does because the mentality of the
democrat party today
is that every disparity income disparity
for example
is the result of a systemic racism
it's not it's the result of individual
choices
wait wait you're not asking anybody
knows why
uh why we have this high black poverty
rate
it's not because they're black there's a
huge black middle class
it's because there's no fathers in the
home
thanks to the democrats welfare system
but if you
say that you're a racist
so it shuts down that side of the debate
what what what's not
communist about it let me ask the
question in a different way let me ask
the question in a different way i'm
really trying to learn from a brilliant
mind like yours
i'm 40 years younger than you i'm trying
to learn from you're 39 i'm 1978. okay
so it's like
you got a lot to teach me and again i'm
gonna ask this from you one more time
in a different way i think there's two
things here that we're talking about
i think democrats are more strategic
you can say manipulative better
marketers than republicans when you said
college education professors
yes i've seen the article that for every
democratic professor there's only one
conservative i know all that data that's
a monopoly that's not a small monopoly
that's a monopoly when i was at harvard
at an
opm program with all these entrepreneurs
and the debate of hillary and trump was
taking place
i watched them screaming every time
hillary said anything
and i watched them boo and these were
professors at harvard
that has 40 billion dollars in their
endowment i
saw how much they hated it wasn't they
were against trump they hated
trump or anything that had to do with
capitalism i'm not talking about this
side
what i'm asking you is the following
here's what i'm asking you because
again i'm gonna i'm planning on being in
the marketplace and competing for a long
time as long as a man upstairs
keeps me healthy healthy i want to
compete i got three kids that i want to
compete as well
i'm asking you the difference between
capitalism
socialism and communism yeah
uh look what's called socialism i mean
bernie sanders
uh of course he's lying says denmark is
his
socialist country the prime minister of
denmark said denmark is not socialist so
we have that problem
but let's take the scandinavian
countries and say that socialism
actually
uh there was something like 85 or 90
percent of their economy
is capitalist communism is this
one it's a one-party system
there's all you have to toe the party
line
the party line is in this country is
already called political
correctness you cannot disagree
with the left without being denounced as
a racist
which is a crime in their minds
and being suppressed their economic
programs are you won't have
you said what did you say 33 taxes
they're gonna tax 90
a hundred trillion dollars where does it
end and it means government ownership of
everything
this is not scandinavian socialism
this is marxist communism there is
communist as fidel castro of us who
by the way when i was a young man i i
fell for his uh you know his
his party line hook line and sinker
he was a new leftist he was neither a
communist nor a capital whatever the
hell he's sitting
he was they lie now um
we have already in this country
the foundations of a totalitarian state
and
and why do i say totalitarian
if you if you listen to any of the these
leftists
every aspect of your life is something
they think is political
people are losing their jobs for a woman
lost her life
this 24 year old mother was murdered
for saying all lives matter this is what
we're up against
it's not the the joe biden time servers
it's the ideologues that are the problem
now
we have 47 states in our country now
that have hate crime legislation
a hate crime is a thought crime
you kill somebody that's a crime
there anybody who kills another human
being is deranged in some way
their motives their intentions
but making it a hate crime makes it a
thought crime i give you an example one
of the first implementations of thought
of
hate crime legislation was three black
kids
went to see the movie mississippi
burning in wisconsin
they came out they were really angry
from what they had seen
and there was a white kid across the
street and one of the three
said let's go f that white kid
up and his two friends
or charge started
going across the street and he said no
no i didn't mean it
literally and they beat the crap out of
this kid and hospitalized him
now all three were charged with the
crime of beating him up
and the guy who said let's go
f him up got an extra two years for the
hate crime
when you have a hate crime
of course it's the hate speech also
you have the foundation of outlawing
anything that you disagree with and
you can see them use it in practice they
call
trump a white supremacist for 30 years
donald trump was a major public figure
everybody in america knew who donald
trump
was but nobody said donald trump white
supremacist
until he ran against the democrats now
why do they call him a white supremacist
because the democrats have a dirty
secret that they're trying to hide
and defend from from the public and that
is that they control
every inner city of size in america 100
and have for 50 to 100 years
every injustice in the interst every
killing field
chicago detroit baltimore st louis
100 controlled by the democrat party and
it has been for 50 to 100 years
every injustice done to blacks real and
imagined in the inner city
democrats are 100 percent responsible
for there's not a republican in sight in
minneapolis
you know or chicago they call trump
a racist to neutralize his critique
of the inner cities and then so let me
ask you let me ask you a simple question
do you think their tactics are going to
stop
no okay then so i agree they're not okay
so this is what i say
based on what you just said is it fair
to say that
everything in a way is a war
that's going on not the kind of war that
you're talking like you know war like
you know
there's a war going on yes yes there's
there's an ideology
war going on today it's a civil war okay
violence
the reason that there's not two armies
is because the federal government is so
powerful
so the war is over control of the white
house once they get that
they're going to start putting people in
jail for
for a hate speech an alleged hate crime
but but i'll give you my my my two cents
on that because this is what i'm trying
to get to with a person like you that
actually
has influence and people listen to you i
call republicans lazy
here's why this is why let me finish and
i want to hear your thoughts well i'm
gonna i'm not disagreeing with you
i i call republicans lazy and short-term
thinkers
why because republicans just said i'll
let them talk as much as they want i'm
just gonna go make my money oh let them
say whatever they want
meanwhile facebook owner left
twitter left youtube google left
new york times left l.a times left time
magazine
left washington post left amazon left
cnn
left abc i can't go on and on you know
it's wall street journal fox fine
everything else is left now here's the
thing the republicans had a chance to
buy twitter for 6 billion they didn't
the republicans had a chance to buy
washington post they didn't the
republicans
had a chance to buy la times for 550
million dollars they didn't
the republicans had a chance to recruit
and build their own schools
and have all these kids go to their
schools with the thoughts of capitalism
and
economy and all that stuff they didn't
do it meanwhile the liberals can't work
berkeley all these other schools that
you went into so my thing is
why [ __ ] about it and find a way to
compete they're not gonna stop you just
said it they're not going to stop
so rather than bitching why don't we
have strategies to compete against it
because
why do republicans create you know
public broadcasting and npr
which are just extreme left institutions
now
they gave it to the left i i agree with
you more
yeah 30 years i spent a voice
crying in the wilderness over this that
when
while we you know i republicans called
leftists and communists liberals
they refer to angela davis who won a
lenin prize
as a liberal they still do it
they call people who hate them liberals
the only liberals in this country are
conservatives and the only people
who believe in two sides to a
conversation and respect for people who
disagree with you
so so yes republicans are cowards
they're lame uh if paul ryan were in the
white house
it would be all over we have a fighter
in trump
uh and that's that's because i think you
know
like i say he's a patriot and he's
somebody
who is not embarrassed about his
credentials since he was a liberal for
so many years
why'd you leave the communist party
yourself i mean
when i was 17 when the russians
invaded when the khrushchev report came
out in 56 i was 17.
and uh and then the russians invaded
hungary
so i was never a kind my parents were
card-carrying communists and everybody
we knew and trusted was a communist
but i was just a young man and i was a
new leftist i
i believed in rescuing socialism
from uh from the communists that's what
made me a new leftist
until the black panther party murdered
uh my friend a woman i had be a mother
of three children i had recruited
uh to do their bookkeeping because i had
created a taxis and foundation for them
is that betty is betty you're talking
about the event
and all my friends said the white power
structure killed her
and i knew i was in it's an evil
movement
shortly thereafter the left won its
biggest victory and
every democrat tries to claim that it
was part of the
he or she was part of the anti-war
movement it wasn't an anti-war movement
when the communists won because
the left forced america to withdraw they
proceeded to slaughter two and a half
million indochinese peasants
and there wasn't one demonstration
against it
i knew i was among an evil movement
which is still an evil movement
and then i dedicated my life after that
to fighting it
barack obama was raised the same way i
was by communists
and he never left the movement never
denounced it
that's true of david axelrod who managed
his campaign and valerie jarrett is his
most important advisor
and billy ayers who ghosted his book
anyway i've been warning about this for
30 or 40 years what's happened is that
obama
weight a lot of conservatives up
we don't have a george soros on the
conservative side
uh you're right they should have bought
things that they didn't buy but
they're still calling them liberals the
hell is liberal about nancy pelosi
these aren't liberals they're vindictive
bigots is what they are
but republicans will call them liberals
then then
uh you know kevin mccarthy will come out
and say
uh here's nancy pelosi saying uh
what does putin have over trump that he
could make this decision
accusing the president united states of
treason
and kevin mccarthy will say the
democrats are playing politics or
pelosi's playing politics
that's not politics that's war
the democrats are at war uh
we have members of the joint chiefs of
staff saying you can't use the military
uh you know to control these rioters
but that's un-american actually
john f kennedy sent the troops the
military into mississippi to integrate
the schools eisenhower
sent the military into little rock to
integrate the schools then
nobody complained about that that's the
responsibility of our military is to
defend us against enemies at home
and abroad and these people are enemies
of america and you know it every time
they open their mouths
i'm half armenian half assyrian okay
and iranian i'm born in iran i was born
in iran but my dad is his last name is
beth david
so that's in the syrian last name beta
house of david
and my mother's armenian borosian you
and i both know about the armenian and
the assyrian and the greek genocide
you know 2.2 million people total you
know we read about it you're seeing
what's going on right now with
azerbaijan and and armenia
the the the atrocity that they're
bringing down and erdogan is supporting
in the same we have to finish what we
started
yeah they're nazis islamic nazis
it's it's it's terrible what's going on
there so
that's two and a half 2.2 million lives
you have the holocaust that took place
41 to 45 you know say 6 million lives
you have slavery that took place for for
many years
and that was millions of lives oh no no
wait a second
what's slavery slavery 400 years of
slavery where
in america owning a slave was legal
excuse me
that's a big leftist lie not that you
left this or are aware of it obviously
correct me it's okay
what would you say it is first of all
and that and that and that is the heart
of the project to destroy america
led by the new york times which is
the gravity of the situation we're in
the 1619
project 400 years
uh includes english colonies america was
created in 1776.
as a matter of fact the times claiming
that there were 20 slaves imported into
virginia is a
is a lie they were indentured servants
and
and slavery was outlawed in virginia in
1619.
um america was 168
years away from being created it was
created in 1776
with a revolutionary proposition
that all men are created equal and have
a god-given right to liberty
from 1770s actually america wasn't
formed until
1787. but from 1776
to 1863 the emancipation proclamation
is 83 years and if you go from 1787
it's less it's 70 whatever 72 years
that's the extent of slavery in america
starting in 1776 the
northern states freed their slaves they
were freed by 1804
the slave trade was abolished by 1808.
why didn't the northern states why did
they make a compromise with the south
because the south was very powerful we
almost
lost the civil war when it was fought 70
years later
the south would have aligned with the
british
who burned the white house in 1812
and slavery would have you know who
knows how much longer it would have
lasted
america gave 350 000
mainly white lives to free the slaves
and the life of a president who was
assassinated because of it
the reality is black africans enslaved
blacks
sold them at auctions in ghana and
benign
and white americans freed them
the democrat party is a racist party and
the whites in it
are self-hating rights to attack america
to allow
al sharpton to give the eulogy the
number two racist in the country
sharpton a convicted liar
uh who never paid by the way the people
that he
libel the let this demagogue
talk about 401 years of america having
its knee on the necks of blacks
america liberated blacks blacks and
slave blacks
that's the reality and the the
duration of slavery in america is a
little over
maybe two generations at that point in
time
fair enough two generations too long is
that a fair estimation to say two
generations too long
okay things don't change over no we
barely won the civil war in 1816
1862-5 slavery is not america's
original sin it's america's original
virtue
that that clarion call for for freedom
all men are created equal and have a
god-given right to liberty
has affected people all over the world
and
and liberated them and the fact that the
new york times
and the left and the democrat party
would want to trash this country's
history
the private uh you know of its sources
of
self-pride and self-worth
shows how dangerous the democrat party
is and why i call it a communist party
as part of it
it's not just about economics communism
it's about having a one-party state
about outlawing
any thought that that you disagree with
and i'm telling you you know these books
white fragility
uh kenny's book that uh a raving racist
uh
tony heasy coates also won a national
book award
for a disgusting book on race
he's a rabid racist who hates america
and america is too damn tolerant that
that's the reality at this point in time
republicans use the appropriate language
when talking about
when democrats accuse the president of
the united states of treason
as swalwell and schiff and all of them
have
without any evidence worse than that
we know now that they knew that the
evidence that they claimed to have
they knew it was lies there was never a
basis for calling trump are you
surprised though why are you surprised
well why are you surprised that they did
that though what what surprise
i'm surprised that you're surprised
because they're they're a traitorous
party
so why are you surprised with that if
you know that why are you surprised with
it
because i grew up with a democrat party
that was an american party it wasn't a
racist party
okay it's not anymore i mean it's not by
the way that's in the open they're not
ashamed to say it that's who they are so
it's not like
democrats say they're racist no no no
democrats or publicly in their games
yeah they're gonna propagate
they're gonna propagate they're gonna
drive their agenda they're gonna
you know do whatever they can to convert
as many people as possible
anything isn't legitimate is it it
doesn't
matter burning portland is not
legitimate
it's not part of the democratic process
it's not it's not it doesn't matter
though what matters is
whatever crisis happens they got to
figure out a way to blame the opposition
i mean that's just
what the game is but there's blame and
blame you can blame trump for you know
he says a lot of things he shouldn't say
i mean
you there's all kinds of legitimate
criticism and you can even
spin it and make it more extreme than it
is but you can't call the president of
the united states
a traitor uh with
knowing that what you're saying is false
then
cook up a 35 million dollar
investigation by a special prosecutor
which crippled the united states ability
you know we had enormous economic
leverage
before the corona are you surprised
though
against you know erdogan
uh you know this is all blown if the
president united you know our enemies
think oh
they're going to impeach this guy i
don't know why you're surprised
i don't know why you're surprised but
let me go back to my question i don't
know
i i don't know i can't understand why
you're not shocked
of course i'm shocked but i'm not
surprised of course they're going to try
to convert as many
it is an atrocity but i'm not surprised
i know when republicans start calling
things by their right names
i think it was confucius it said that if
you you want
justify justice in the world you have to
rectify the names
when the democrats are called the
racists that they are
i'll know that we have a chance of
winning
right now we're losing this country
rapidly
my question armenian genocide two and a
half million lives two point two two two
and a half million lives
holocaust six million slavery in u.s
according to your estimation
87 years from 1776 to 1863 emancipation
proclamation cost 350 000
lives and the assassination of a
president this is my question
um as an armenian
myself i get a lot of people that call
me and they'll say pat
we have to figure out a way to make this
armenian genocide official in u.s
they're not doing it and it passed
congress it passed senate but trump
didn't sign it why didn't he sign it
erdogan
you know worries we have three military
bases there what if we do that he's
gonna
do this it's gonna be a bad ally we need
them in the middle it's fine
holocaust happens to the jewish
community
travesty we've seen read all about it
but jews became very very good
in business in hollywood in many
different areas
extremely successful so the values and
principles that went from after an
atrocity
that came in this happened let's go
prove our
selves right small community or jewish
community it's not 50 100 200 million
people that small
they became very successful the question
i'm asking you is the following
i always get into debates reparation
you know america owes uh uh the
african-american community 14 trillion
dollars three trillion whatever these
numbers are that come up
what i'm asking you here's my question
here's my question here's my question
what do you think is the right approach
to take
that other nationalities can take to say
look we just want to know that this
event has validated that it happened
and then from there we want to be able
to move on and go about our lives
what did the jewish community do right
to move on with their lives and become
successful that's a huge problem
what the jews had going for them
were the allies in world war ii and we
fought
were against hitler um it changed
america's attitudes but that's why
segregation
the days were numbered after the war we
fought against
a master race
movement the nazi movement
um the problem now is you have the
democrat party
is in bed with the islamic nazis
uh which would include erdogan you can't
criticize
muslims you just can't i mean the
democrat party is in full
trump doesn't have the maneuvering room
there he doesn't have a united front
he's got
saboteurs democrat parties out to
sabotage everything he does including
his foreign policy
while we're a divided country like that
uh you know i feel for the armenians i
i'm getting old so i don't names are
very they slip out of your head but
but there's a famous book about armenia
that i read
armenians are kind of like jews even
though they're christians
and they were slaughtered because they
were christians
and islam is a bigoted religion
anybody who knows anything about islam
knows it's a religion of bigots they
destroyed the two uh 2500 year old
buddhas they've just
taken um you know the
cathedral that was at the center of uh
grief of greek orthodoxy and turned it
into a mosque
they built a mosque on the holiest
site that the jews have um you know they
want to exterminate the jews
and probably you know probably
anybody who will not probably but
they've been incited by their prophet
to do that to anybody who doesn't submit
to their faith
they're they're a menace you know and
the hypocrisy
is off the charts because you don't hear
democrats complaining about the chinese
persecution of the uyghur uh muslims do
you
because the democratic party is also in
bed with the chinese
communists i i we're just in a very
dangerous situation in america
i wish i could i can't give you advice
on what to do about
the armenian genocide but i think you
should keep
pressing it it's very important for
people to know
uh not not just for the armenians but
for christians everywhere
i wrote a whole book on the war against
christians
um and the democratic party is at war
with christianity
the pursuit of the little sisters of the
poor by the obama administration just
the fact that they shut down churches
and
open bars during the coronavirus
crisis shows what their attitude towards
believing christians are
and jews okay all right last thing we're
going to do here is speedrun i'll give
you a name tell me one word that comes
to mind hillary clinton
one word one word rich
rich okay biden
political [ __ ] bernie sanders
communist aoc
aaron pelosi
evil witch susan rice
pathological liarson mike pence
he's a really decent person one of the
most decent people in politics
kamala harris she she's
also a racist racist liar
barack obama traitor
uh karl marx
crackpot ein rand
she's a very bad writer but uh
her her philosophy
is better than most
donald trump uh he's
an american hero an american hero
david horowitz thank you so much for
being a guest folks if you're watching
this we're going to put the link below
to his book to get a copy called blitz
trump will smash the left and win once
again david thank you so much for being
a guest on valuetainment what a pleasure
pat and it's a pleasure meeting you and
getting to know
that there's somebody like you out there
thank you thank you likewise
so if you like this interview i have
another interview i want you to watch
it's similar to one when i sat with
dennis prager at his house
he's having a cigar there's two dogs
right next to us i'm petting one of them
and it also got pretty interesting and
heated out a couple times now him and i
have done this a few times
and every time we do we have a good time
but if you've not watched my sit down
with dennis prager
i think you'd enjoy it and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
[Music]
bye